telling us how the structure of human
functions small stuff okay yeah so thank
you for kind so just for their credit
spot this is our junk work with um I'm
your scuba and I wish I tell so okay so
this is the title of the talk now how's
this oh yes i'll probably don't need to
tell you what the fourier transform is
right we're all among friends here so i
just put the slide so we we can
understand my indentation so i think
just stop William function the function
from the group Z 2 to the N into the
real number is plus or minus 1 and then
we have those Fourier curve tails Kyle
power of X which are on orthonormal
basis and we just represent the function
as a linear combination of those the
characters sum over alpha for every
alpha is e to the n of f hat alpha chi
of out chi alpha of x that just probably
known so the interaction between the
free transforming computation can
actually go both ways you can assume
that the function has a low complexity
in a certain computational model and
then like to say facts about its furious
structure so an example is like the
linear Monceau a nice on paper which
says that any function which is computed
by a small dip circuit as most of its
full-year weight is light lies on the
low levels in this stock we actually go
in the opposite direction we assume
several restrictions on the Fourier
spectrum of the function and then we ask
what does it say about the complexity of
functions certain computation models so
I'm going to define what what
restriction I make on the Fourier
spectrum in which computational models
i'm considering over the next few slides
so let's start with complexity to comply
message so there are many things you can
define here I'm going to concentrate on
to so the first is the dispositive
that's a closely related to the open
problem John and asked yesterday so the
spice do you ever use that this notation
is just the number of nonzero for your
coefficient to write just the
cardinality of of this set and exon no
more the l1 norm is just the sum of the
Fourier coefficient in absolute value
right somewhere alpha of F hat of alpha
in absolute value so will be mostly
concerned with the spectral norm in this
talk as the title suggests but
dispositive also have to to keep in mind
okay so as usual with this thing if you
just you know pick a function randomly
after out of the box you're going to end
up with a function both the large
spectrum Norman large positive I mean
that's how random function behave so you
want is you want to understand I mean
what does it mean to have a small
spectral norm or a small spot city I
mean how does how you got those function
look so let's just give our sort of
large family of function with small
specks on norm so if you have a function
which is an indicated function or a
characteristic function of a coset or an
offense I'll space or affairs e to the n
then it's back on all this constant its
most three so it doesn't matter i mean
what n is or what did i mention it's
always bounded by three examples for
these functions include the end function
that's not usually how you would think
about the end function but to just an
indicator function of one point so it's
a concept of zero subspace or the or
function the xor function obviously
satisfies this these properties all have
bounded spectral norm and this actually
turns out to be a pretty good
characterization so this is the
following theorem by green and Sanders
what they say is so consider your given
function with spectral norm a
yeah just some real number a then what
they claim is that you can write this
function as a linear combination of
indicated function of subspaces sum over
i equals 1 to l and l is at most this
thing 2 to the 2 to the 0 of a to the
fourth so you might think it's scary
this w explanation thing but the
important thing is that it doesn't
depend on em so like the only way you
can generate functions with a [ __ ] with
constant spectral norm is have just take
a linear combination of constantly many
indicators of subspaces yes exactly yes
or maybe you can even zoom without plus
one but never mind so that's a that is
theorem it's so again it shows some
characterization of my of those function
with very low spectrum now so let's move
on to talk about the computational
models so the first thing I wanted to
mention is the decision tree which even
if you didn't know so that's what you
have no I mean just that we do compete
billion function when every internal
node you queria variable if it's zero
you move on to the left side three if
you are one you move on to the right
subtree and on the leaves you have
boolean labels so this tree for example
computes the majority function over
three bits obviously open compute any
function so you define the depth of the
tree to be the longest path from the
root to any leaf of the tree and you
denote by D of F the minimum depth
decision tree which computes F so it
turns out the decision tree is not
strong enough for us what we need is a
sort of a stronger version of it which
is a parrot a decision tree which is
exactly the same except that now you're
allowed in every internal node to query
just any linear function of your input
bits so like you choose a subset s you
query the sum of X I module to a new
branch accordingly so actually are in
our notation it is more convenient to
think about it as if you just square in
kya of of X for some alpha somehow the
labels a 1-1 but it's a exactly the same
thing and we use this notation like deal
with a parity of F that's the mineral
depth of any parties decision 34 f so
obviously this is always at most a
decision tree death because any decision
trees in particular parity decision tree
where all the queries are just queries
of single variables and we're going
we're going to also use this size parity
of F which is the mineral size where we
measure measure size by a number of
leaves
so let's think about the xor function
for example so it's parity decision to
is very simple right you only need one
query wine linear query the variables to
compute its value whereas I mean if you
think about its decision tree it's going
to be very large you're listening to
Khloe all individual variables in order
to to know the value of the function so
this parity decision to is actually are
stronger than the usual decision trees
okay are we good patient again so let's
state the obvious connection between
parity decision trees and the complexity
measure I I mentioned so let's assume F
Istanbul and function which is computed
by a parity decision tree with depth D
in size s then I claim that its spectral
norm is at most s which is most to to
the D and its positives at most s time
to to the deal which is most 42d you get
this balance by simply like you have a
tree and you write to function as a sum
of indicators for the leaves and that's
that's the bounce you get and they are
tight inside several paces but but again
it's nice to know I mean can you get me
the steering for this fact I mean can
any function I mean if I give a function
with small specks on lomas most positive
can you find a small small sized or
small depth decision tree which
represented which computes it so I'm not
defining small in this in this slide I'm
just asking a general question and what
we're going to have some partial ounces
and and done mention like a major open
problem in this in answering this
question so we're going to get back to
it so let's the state like AB several of
our results so suppose again you give a
function respect on lomas a so are the
first thing we do is that we identify
some sort of local structure of F so we
claim that there's some subspace and F
in subspace V of Z to the N it's called
a mansion at most a squared such that F
must be constant
on be so again you can think about it
you in constant contrast to the green
Sanders result they have this sort of
global characterization of f of the sum
of indicators then we find like a local
structure in F which must exist for such
function and again if a is constant for
example then there must be this really
huge subspace such that F is constant on
all of this subspace another thing we do
is we give a bound on the parity
decision tree side of F which is at most
a distinct 2 times n to the a squared so
again for the case that a is constant
which is quite interesting it must have
a polynomial size parity decision tree
okay so I mean it's this decide to you
can't down or acquaintance with banners
decision tree so I mean sorry about the
size not the depth but yet you have
you'll get a parity constant size
decision tree no the green Sun is all
that doesn't give our decision tree I
mean it's only like a sound V indicators
I mean how do you get uh huh each sub
space is just recruit the Sun yeah but
that me
and queries when then it's cute oh right
but if you quit the values of all the
subspaces then you know the something
you can do yeah but coming too pretty to
value of all the subspaces that may be
much larger than M which is all the
subspaces tables yeah so again they have
I mean like some of I equals 1 to l 0 1
that's called you I so you can query
like a like a basis of a few i do oh if
you want to know what's up when you I
effects but that may be much larger than
M event I mean so they don't give you
any guarantees about this you ice yeah
they give like I mean I mean okay you
may hate me you may look at poof and try
to figure out something but it doesn't
work like out of the box cause some code
damage no no no there would be the end
function yeah so again this may be like
indicate of one point so you have to
query and queries to the richest and
then you're already worse than the
trivial pengen you can invent the notion
of like a coset decision tree where each
guy gets to query a cassette and then
they'll give you a casa decision tree of
depth to to the a to the fourth but you
can't turn that into a pair a decision
tree very easily yeah but how I mean how
do you create a cosign that muff maybe
binary tree right
you can just go with Casa top 20
subspace you're in and just you know
know the value obtained but no it just
says whether or not you're in the closet
so there will still be a binary tree
okay yeah I guess you could you could do
that yeah so so again so the greensand
result result doesn't give an obvious
decision tree in this does so next time
we also have bounds on the depth of
their decision tree which is a squared
time log of the sparsity remember the
disparity is the number of 10 fougere
coefficient if you're willing to set up
on an approximation of F like epsilon
approximation then I mean for every
epsilon greater than 0 we can give a 3
of this death a squared plus log 1 over
epsilon which computes a function which
is an epsilon approximation for app and
you can also learn this efficiently I'm
obviously this is informal I'm going to
get to what i mean by learning but let's
take this statement as is right now and
finally I claim that everything is
basically holds for function if you take
a function from Z P to the N to wear
plus minus 1 so it's not only for
people's too but for every p are some
it's not exactly i mean do i need to add
some constant some in some places and
some of them will depends on pink a
polynomial dependent on ping i think too
yes but yeah but as the basic proofs and
techniques everything goes along also
for is it is EP now the remarkable thing
here that essentially all of these
proofs are going to be called
corollaries of a very simple lemma which
i'm going to show you and then so i'm
going to show the lemma when we just
going to present some of the proofs
assuming the lemma and at the end we're
going to talk about the proof of the
lemma which is also not hard are so
let's just stay the main jana so again
suppose you
some boolean function which sparkled on
a and let's just add some patient a fat
halfa would be the largest coefficients
and in absolute value and f had better
is the second largest and let's just
denote by this thing f restricted to chi
alpha plus beta equals e the restriction
of F to this subspace or F in subspace
if that is equals minus 1 then when I
claim is that you can find be I mean
either 10 minus 1 such that if you
restrict F to the subspace on which kyle
topless beta equals B the spectral norm
drops by at least a minus the absolute
value of F hat of alpha which is also at
least n minus 1 over a that saw post
about the identity and if you stick to
minus B then respect unknown drops by at
least a third of beta now if you think
about it like I in a parity distinct
resetting the new I mean you begin with
some some function which the speculum a
and like on this side you you get to a
sub function the spectral norm is a
minus 1 over a and on this a minus i phi
beta 0 let's consider like the end
function for example so the add function
it really has like one special points
like they do on the old one input it's
minus one and in other cases it is one
so actually it actually doesn't matter i
mean which direction they're all in
spirit spectrum is like it has this
large constant term like 1-2 to the
minus n or something like that and all
the others are really tiny so so if you
think about the advection it doesn't
matter which direction your query you're
going to end up with a constant function
one on one side of the Queen and on the
other side of the two you're going to
have just the end function on n minus
one more variables so I mean on this
side you pretty much gain nothing I mean
just really tiny fraction of the
spectral norm but on this side you
actually get to a constant function
okay that's a clear ah I mean that's the
lemma but if you want ok so what a tad
bit is because then
are so yeah so I mean that's so f f/a
DeFalco must be at least one over a
that's very you can do Possible's their
fear and you get what to get the second
one may be really tiny and that's like
the end function so in some cases you
you almost get nothing okay so that's
the main lemma so let's um let's move on
to some proofs just assume the main line
is true so let's prove this thing again
so I'm restating the theorem you have a
function with specs on long a and I'm
going to find a sub for sub space with
co dimension a squared on which F is
constant so it which must share obvious
what I'm about to do right I'm just
going to apply the main lemma and get a
restriction or respect how long is a
minus 1 over a and then I'm going to do
it again I mean right but if it works
one time let's be going and after at
most a squared times I'm gonna end up
with a function which pic well-known one
which must be a linear function so if
it's not constant than just our again so
it's just really an iterative
application of the main lemma like a
square time you get to the end of
restrictions and I'm just going to
mention that this was kind of sloppy if
you actually try to figure out what
going on you are you can see that the
collimation of V can be is actually of a
I mean it's exactly the same algorithm
you just analyze it more carefully and
that's an independent work by at shang
wang xi and junk are
okay let's show another thing that's
like but the bounds on the parity
decision tree size like two times M to
the P squared so the proof is simply
simply by induction of on em so let's I
mean let's define this thing like el Fna
it's the maximum overall function which
Specter along with most of the size of
the decision feel like the worst
function you can think of in this term
with among all our function which spec
for a moment most a and take the its
size so again we use the mainland on
wave like consider the tree which start
by preparing the chi alpha plus beta so
I mean here we have a love and an a on
this side the speculum drops by at least
one over a and the number of variables
drops by one where and on this side we
basically assume nothing except that the
number of variables is now n minus 1 and
you basically just get this recursion
and you solve it so again also you can
do slightly better I mean you can get it
to be a two to the a squared times m to
the a and basically the way you do it is
that like you wearing the fact that
either the largest coefficient is very
big like a half or if it's less than a
half then they also their second largest
must be quite big like 1 over 2a or
something like that so you just analyze
both cases and you you push it down
further to to this thing so this has two
nice corollaries the first thing that is
self an analog to the to the green and
Sanders result I mean if you have a
decision tree you can just write it as
some of indicators of subspaces by again
just picking every leaf and taking the
big indicator function of this subspace
and the bound is 2 to the I squared n to
the a so so we call that winning Sanders
has 2 to the 2 to the 0 of a fourth so I
mean it's sort of an incomparable I mean
so
are we have depends on n and obviously I
mean to take the end function show you
can say the size of the decision for
even for function with small vector no
must depend on n but but you get a
parity decision p which is nice and also
like if a is not super small then
actually this thing is better I mean for
constant a is the degree no senders
resolved as a no it is not known so
actually there's old theater is much
more general it actually works for every
year we function from any a billion
group either one or even if it doesn't
even have to be boolean but to never
mind so for general groups if no it is
known that you need at least exponential
in the spectral norm but not for for ZTE
to the N or Z P to the N so it's
actually a good open problem to try to
improve this thing to something better
yeah it may be polynomial a second thing
you can get is if you think of boolean
formulas like you know which end and or
and not gates and bounded Fanning and
all this stuff then you can get a size
at 22 x squared n to the eight times n
squared will then formula for any
function with respect on long a and then
since you can always balance formulas if
you get the you get this depth so if a
is constant this means F is in the
complexity class MC that's now put it up
with Macbeth and polynomial size I think
so this is just you your induction on
the side of the dream it's basically a
minute all right
so let's talk about learning theory for
a moment so our limit our learning model
is the following will we considered that
our pack model with membership queries
which is just the language theory lingo
for a black buck access to a function f
and you measure your error with
according to the uniform distribution if
you want to output with high probability
and a path disease gene with the
probability of x of f of x is not equal
to g of x is as most epsilon you want
the running time obviously to be
something good so I mean polynomial in n
1 over epsilon and a lot one of the
Delta R so this problem has been
considered before it is this very famous
paper by cosi levitt monster which says
that a if function has aspect unknown a
then you just take the a squared of
epsilon largest fully proficient you
truncate right the largest you take the
sign and that's a very good that's an
epsilon approximation for F and what's
even more important is that you can
using those membership queries actually
learn which are the largest coefficient
and approximate values so you just
output g as your hypothesis and which
very good probability in the time
polynomial in n 1 over epsilon log 1
over delta oh yes but what if you insist
on a parity decision 34 g so I mean duck
they did the most natural thing you can
do it just query all this linear
function one by one button you get a
depth of a squared over epsilon I mean
essentially this without knowing
anything better about G that's the best
thing you can do so what we do is we
actually construct an app's parity
decision tree so you're given a function
a you have a black block access and you
construct a parity decision tree of this
that which computes a function G which
is an epsilon approximation for F so the
running time is polynomial in n in the
size of the decision tree which
maybe exponential in any sport and one
over epsilon and log 1 over Delta so I
have you just dislike tape of the
comparison so so Allah ipods these sizes
like obviously much larger I mean if you
think of three of that a squared is its
size can be polynomial in there it can
be exponentially a all of it's sort of
like you do much more pre-processing and
you get a better hypothesis you get
disparity decision trees which which
depth a squared to slope 1 over epsilon
and as opposed to I mean here you have
to query on the function so that's a
squared over epsilon and if you consider
the case where your function is given as
a parity decision tree which is actually
a case the crucial evidence to consider
then just give you a proper learning
algorithm where they give a polynomial
threshold function so let's see how we
do it so I'm going to define like a very
simple thing that's the the bias of
boolean function is just the the
absolute value of the probability that
is 1 minus the probability that is minus
1 so like if the function is constant
this equals 1 and if its balance it
equal to 0 it measures how far is it
from constant and you're going to use a
recursive their construction so you can
last at most ke steps where K is this
thing you just like a bound of the death
of the recursion i'm bout to make so i
have to stopping condition 1 is i reach
k levels and the second is i arrived at
a very highly biased function with
biased more than 100 minus epsilon and
what do we do again we just apply the
main lemma right we do this thing
essentially we arrive in some function
with speculum a prime and we queried the
two largest coefficient and on this side
you get a prime minus 1 over a prime and
here i pi minus g at beta and all this
goes on for K levels let's
I to analyze the error I mean what's
going on here so I mean several things
in k can can happen whenever you are
whenever you level you either make a
good move like more respectful norm
drops by a lot or you make a bad move
for who knows what happens and it may be
the case like like after the three
queries URL where you arrive at a
constant function which is great you
just stop are you may be like querying
also to clean your function and this is
where I ran out of Greek letters so I
chose que Ella and you will get 2 minus
1 which is so this this is like grayish
background I mean the function here is
very biased toward minus 1 that is not
exactly minus 1 but again you just stop
it's highly biased toward minus 1 and it
may be the case that you create k linear
function and you get to leave for the
sub functions can be almost balanced I
mean no one knows what's going on there
so so let's analyze the error of this
thing I mean more where do dear come
from our I'm just going to mention that
I mean to prove the theorem just take
these three and you replaced every leaf
with the constant like temp the majority
value so if you're a constant that's
great if you're highly biased that's
obvious what to do and if you're almost
balanced then you just pick the majority
and also that I mean how do you learn it
you just on every node you just learn
the two largest coefficient using
crucial divestment sir algorithm and
then you move on down the tree so we
just left with analyzing the error so we
need to do this sort of like average of
over all the leaves so this constant
leaves a great right i mean any inputs
which follows this path is correct
because here the function is constant
these highly biased leaves are also
great because there's an absolute
fraction of all the inputs which follow
this path which are which are incorrect
but it's only like a small fraction so
it's good so like my only hope to save
the day is just claiming that's not many
inputs arrive to this this
so I mean maybe half of the inputs which
arrived you are incorrect but by the
claim is that that they aren't that many
inputs which arrived left to begin with
yeah so that's so that's what we need to
show so again let's let's figure out
what's going on here so on every
internal node you have half of the
inputs following a good path or the norm
drops by one over a and a half of the
inputs follow maybe not good password I
don't know what happens so and obviously
you can't you can't follow more than a
squared path which reduces known without
arriving at a constant function because
you begin with a and you it drops by one
over a on every on every step so so I
mean the question is how many inputs
make that many bad moves I mean you you
really have to to make a lot of bad
decisions in your life in order to get
to an non-biased vignon non-biased leaf
after such many queries so we called k
was a was 10 10 a squared so we're like
an expectation you would expect that
after 2a squared moves you would be
you'd have a squared good moves so the
probability of following a path with
such a high length with other writing to
a constant is the most is exponentially
small okay which is most excellent okay
well
the exact largest right but I mean it's
it's it's enough to find with the
approximate oh yeah even if you're a
young you have approximated for the
largest we've actually only need to know
you don't have to we'll know the vet
their values you just have to know which
which do a largest but but even if
you're incorrect with approximated in
value and you get to which are not the
largest but large enough it still works
yeah so uh so so again that I just
repeat what happened we had this because
of construction where we do it for at
most def ki or when we arrived to a lip
which is biased and then we figure out
that for the most epsilon fraction of
the inputs this tree is funk oh yeah so
this is an example of a highly biased
three you can see it so so let's just
talk about the proof ID of the main nana
without giving all the details so just
remember what it says you have this
function with speculum a and on one side
you lose a minus the absolute value of F
at alpha and on this side f at beta
where alpha and beta are the two largest
just to make simplifying assumptions to
make my life easier that just assume
alpha is zero and I've had zero in beta
of the same sign this is extremely not
important this is just for the very less
locations in those slides it works
anyway so let's think what happened in
the free domain when you restrict a
function on on linear function on a
subspace on which guy beta equals 1 or
minus 1 so what I claim is that are for
every gana this two guys have had ramen
F at beta + gamma the oak they both
collapse to the same fourier coefficient
when it's going to have this absolute
fact I mean hi de plus or minus we have
the pan
plus or minus here so like before we are
can arrange the mall in pairs like if
I've got one and f of gamma 1 plus beta
and gamma 2 in gamma 2 plus beta these
are basically just the if you think of
it it's the concept of the additive
subgroup which is generated by better
which consists of beta and 0 and after
the every spare collapse collapse to do
the same to the same coefficient let's
consider what happens if we restrict on
Chi beta equals minus 1 let's call it f
prime so before we had to cut patient f
out of 0 and F out of bed and their
contribution to the speckle gnome with
just the sum of those two values and now
we have F at 0 0 minus F out of beta and
the contribution is this thing so recall
we had this assumption that they have
the same sign so like it think for
example both are positive so here you
get this son if you get the difference
so you actually joke or like for this
pair you you've saved 2 times the
absolute value of F at beta and we call
and let's go back to this slide for a
moment so every other pair cannot
increase obviously the spectral norm
because of the triangle inequality so
every every pair either either em or
subtract one another so it can it cannot
increase so for this pair we save
something and that's what we get so
obviously this is like the easy part
coming if you the real action is if you
restrict on Chi beta equals 1 so I'm not
going to do is it's going to take some
time I mean that i can assure its really
simple nothing fancy going on there if
you want to say just come by later so
let me just state that essentially again
everything I said also our works for
those kind of function f from z p to the
n to plus minus 1 for any
NP you have to do like more technical
work there too to get things going now
basically due to the fact that now the
free characters are not boolean function
they take the like two complex roots of
unity or for AP and now the coefficients
are complex so you can't really do this
trick like assume they're at the same
sign or different sign you need to work
a little harder but but it works I mean
everything go so let's mention some open
problems so the first thing is that
exactly what the what John said
yesterday at this conjecture which was
made by Zhang and she and Montaner and
husband so for every boolean function f
its parity decision tree depth is at
most is part logarithmic in the sparsity
so we call we had this are all the
parties to this injury that most a
squared time log positing so so I mean
if it's true when a is small like a
logarithmic and especially but in
general inkay can be as large as the
square root the sparsity so so this is
still open apparently it's been like
floating around in quite a few circles
so I've had the original motivation for
this thing was the log run conjecture if
you can see the function I capital f of
X and Y is just this lowercase F which
depends on X X or Y just like bitwise
XOR so for this function the rank is
exactly the sparsity of F so on we don't
know much we know several things the
first is that this cannot be too tied
this C must be at least log of 6 to the
base 3 which is 1.63 if you're in with
the kind of stuff i mean you can
probably recognize this mysterious
constant where it comes from it
basically like the function which
separates
the deterministic complete communication
complexity from the log-rank is under
construction another thing which is
known that this is equivalent to the
following thing which seems easier that
for any boolean f you can find the
subspace V with koda mention that most
part logarithmic in the sparsity such
that F restricted to V is constant so
again here yet like you require you
require tree with I mean this obviously
implies this because if that's the depth
of the tree than any path with this
depth make f constant this seems weaker
but is actually equivalent and you can
even be more brave and conjecture that
you can replace here f hat of 0 x f 51
respectful norm this congestion was made
by a Sangha at all and again some if you
consider their size of a parity decision
before appt so it's kind of annoying it
we have this exponential dependence on a
we want to get it to be polynomial in a
and a that seems reasonable we don't
know how to do it and also it was
mentioned like improving the green and
Sanders result that's that's a good open
problem all right so thank you
yeah that was the the proof of the the
other case of the main lemon which I
didn't show but that's that's a good
question the pilot show works for for
any F yeah let's just do it some on the
board so so let's let's say we had this
assumption that they're out of 0 are
just out of beta I just and we also
assume they have the same side so now we
are we're considering that F double
prime which is f restricted Chi data
equals 1 so again we have these dis
collapse right of every like a rate of
Ghana and a tired of gamma plus beta H
those do basically collapse to the same
one this time with a plus so if so the
last camp comes from pairs with
different signs right because this time
if they had the same sign that this sum
is just the sum and they have different
saying you do something so what you want
to bounce is like once found are the sum
over gamma such that f had of Ghana I'm
EDF half gamma plus beta is negative of
the minimum
postal best
right because if they have different
sign their different sign and I have
been together then that's what I say for
every pair in the spectral norm up to a
factor of two or maybe like over cutting
cutting twice each pair but now never
mind ah so
so here's the crucial part like when you
use the boolean G of f you claim that x
squared is equal to 1 equals 1 that's so
obvious and in the Fourier setting that
means that for all pay a nonzero beta
you have that some F out of gamma sum
over gamma if I'd of gamma have had of
gamma plus theta equals 0 that's
convolving I've had with sweet itself Oh
No so okay so I'm not going to do the
calculation but you basically you have
you like one gum equals zero you have 0
and beta and gamma equals beta you have
baton zero and you get that are like up
four times I've had a beta that most are
just some over those gamma which are
negative this product okay so I'm
actually doing the whole pain never mind
and this is most so we call that fr the
beta was the second-largest and yeah so
I mean I can take up some value and this
is less than f of beta times what I
wanted to bounce
ok
any other questions all right